thank you joe a crash involving a semi  truck killed two women and shut down the  i-15 near gene for hours earlier this  morning according to nhp the driver of  that honda slammed into the back of the  semi the impact took out the back tires  of the truck sent the car flying off the  road investigators are trying to  determine why the driver of the honda  did not slow down before the collision  with highway speeds of at least 65 miles  an hour you know speed is always a  factor and you need to be always aware  of your surroundings as well as  what other drivers are doing you need to  make sure you're paying full attention  you know don't be on your cell phone to  be messing with the radio because  anything can happen in that fast of a  second  the two women inside the honda were  killed the truck driver is not injured  nhp saying it's too early to tell if  impairment played a role in any of this